freundin und drei
passion ist mein leben
und mein leben ist mir heilig und was
mir auch heilig ist ist germany's next
topmodel
von daher schon wir uns heute gemeinsam
die models der staffel 2005
fangen wir doch einfach mal direkt an
mit der maria
das ist maria
maria ist buchbinderin und hat schon als
kleines kind von einer karriere als
model geträumt du hast davon geträumt
aber löws von münzenberg war schon
längst model als er noch im pakt auch
wahr machen wir weiter mit der lieben
larissa hier vorne das ist sie
stabiler mache weiter mit der lieben
liliana hier vorne das ist die jana
thomann habt ihr alle gleiche kanne oder
war die jana ist 21 jahre alt kommt aus
rheda wiedenbrück und liliana beschreibt
sich als authentisch einzigartig und
pflichtbewusst ich würde mich einfach
nur als topmodel beschreiben
jasmin ist die nächste kandidatin meine
lieben freunde das ist jasmin
die hat sich ein beispiel genommen
sandra mit dem leoparden oberteil
sie ist 21 und studiert in wien denn die
gebürtige passauerin studiert in wien ja
das liegt dann auch nana ist die nächste
kandidatin die wir uns hier heute
anschauen das ist nämlich lee
sie ist 20 jahre alt und studentin aus
neuen nennen sie studiert bwl und
beschreibt sich als kleiner sonnenschein
also ich bin ein grosser sonnenschein
waren abschuss das hier ist ali shah sie
ist die sechste kandidaten die wir uns
heute anschauen sie ist 19 jahre alte
abiturientin aus berlin
sie machte in ihrer frühen jugend fort
kommen wir als nächstes hierzu alexandra
und so alexandra steht hier das die 21
jahre alt ist und aus köln kommt
linda ist die nächste teilnehmerin hier
sie hat ein gelbes hemd daten sie damit
ein bisschen aus wie ein schiedsrichter
allerdings
ist sie 20 jahre alt und auszubildende
auszubildende aus nidda 11
machen wir weiter mit marie sophie einen
sehr gewagten style hier an den tag legt
man weiß allerdings natürlich immer nie
ist das deren wirklicher style oder die
und haben gesagt kommen wir wollen dass
du so auftritt wer weiß wer weiß marie
sophie es auf jeden fall 19 jahre alt
kommt aus konstanz simons in minecraft
ein ehemaliger raf- youtuber sich einen
dams überlegt hat
konstanz
es kommen
abends
machen wir weiter mit der nächsten
kandidaten namens luca
ja luca ist 19 jahre alte abiturientin
aus bitterfeld wolfen de luca hat die
abitur absolviert und hobbymäßig schon
gebuddelt so wie ich
nur dass bei mir halt nicht hobbymäßig
war sondern ich habe einfach daran auch
millionen verdient haben
das ist das meine lieben freunde und da
ist 20 jahre alt kommt aus solingen und
wurde in der ukraine geboren sagte
ukraine oder ukraine
2005 kamen sie mit ihren eltern nach
deutschland die 20 jährige spielt seit
zwölf jahren gitarre außerdem tanz
zeichnet und singt sie sehr gerne ist es
schön
was ich nur gern als model
lena ist die nächste kandidatin fährt
hier mit ihrem fahrrad rom 27 jahre alte
studiert in main-spessart real
studentinnen und wurde auf ein land sie
hat immer ein lächeln auf den lippen und
lebt nach dem motto sei die veränderung
die du dir in der welt wünscht ich war
wette 10.000 euro das sie dass sie ihrer
ins tableau stehen dort amina ist die
nächste teilnehmerin sie ist 21 jahre
alt und studiert in berlin im sechsten
semester soziologie oh mein gott wenn er
wirklich leute dabei halt nicht mehr
erreicht als ich denn ich bin model das
hier ist mira und mira ist eine 19
jährige studentin aus bordesholm dicker
was es in deutschland alles für städte
gibt ne
wahnsinn mira ist sehr zielstrebig und
lässt sich durch nichts aus der ruhe
bringt ja wenn ich sehen würde
erst dann wäre ruhe für dich das
geringste problem
ich habe schon in meiner kindheit
alles aus der ruhe gebracht
ordentlich für aufsehen gesorgt
er fühle ich mich auch wohl
aus
das hat mit da hatte ich durchfall und
dann haben mich anderen in
basketballkorb
mareike aufforderten kari amrum putzen
hier
sie ist 25 jahre alt damit gehört
wahrscheinlich zu den ältesten bis vor
kurzem war basketball ihre große
leidenschaft ich habe auch zwei groß
dass es ashley meine lieben freunde die
posieren die alle an den gleichen orten
ist ein bisschen
die hätten jetzt natürlich nicht nach
thailand australien und amerika fliegen
können erstellt studiert jura und
donauwörth ii kann jura da muss ich mich
ganz schön verpassen die kann mich
wahrscheinlich mit jeder aussage die ich
hier tätige hobbs nehmen nana ist die
nächste teilnehmerin sie ist 19 jahre
alt und abiturienten aus hamburg
gewonnen geworden müssen wir gar nicht
mehr lesen
romina ist 21 jahre alt und kommt aus
köln
ich wohne ich werden in köln habe dabei
sechs jahre gewohnt also romina gute
wahl
romina ist selbstständig und begeistert
über 85.000 abonnenten auf ihrem
instagram auch gott comeback vanessa
hier meine lieben freunde sie sieht aus
wie eine schauspielerin finde ich
eins zu eins gut vanessa als 21 jahre
alt studentin und ist ein mit
die karla ist die nächste praktiker
praktikantin bin ich las vegas die
nächste teilnehmerinnen und sie ist 21
jahre und studenten auf hin
pinneberg bei hamburg klar logisch kader
an eine leidenschaft fürs schreiben in
ihrer freizeit verfasst sie aus ihrer
eigenen kurzgeschichte ein buch das
möchte sie unbedingt veröffentlich in
die studentin in klammern
wirtschaftspsychologie meditiert zwei
bis dreimal an
es gibt halt solche und solche
praktikanten
teilnehmer
es gibt hier die wirtschaftspsychologie
studenten die nebenbei ein eigenes buch
herausbringen und meditieren
hmm
und dann gibt es die mit 580 1000 leuten
auf instagram das hier ist die soul in
ich hoffe man spricht das richtig aus
sie ist 20 jahre alt und abiturienten
aus hamburg auch gewonnen bauen wir gar
nicht weiter reden ist die nächste show
bis jetzt ein zu voller durch die
verwandten in den laden chanel ist eine
20-jährige auszubildende aus eric und
schnell macht eine ausbildung zur
erzieherin ich muss auch mal dringend
was ich erzogen
das hier ist romy wie nimmt auch teil an
der diesjährigen staffel gntm dass es
logisch weil sonst wer sich in diesem
video mit dritten kombi nun allerdings
auch schon zur letzten kandidaten die
bei der diesjährigen staffel gntm 2021
mit dabei ist und zwar as sarah
ohne h diesmal der pulli es sieht nach
merching
allerdings sollte es nicht um
merchandise gehen sondern um sarah denn
sie ist 20 jahre alt und studentin aus
aichtal bei stuttgart ii studentin hat
bereits model erfahrungen gesammelt ihre
guten chance mit gntm 17 ihrem r11 in
ihrem einzigartigen und
außergewöhnlichem look musik ist die
große leidenschaft der 20 jährigen haben
liebsten deckt die neue songs oder geht
auf konzerte auf das ist jetzt natürlich
blöd mitbewohner allerdings gut es ist
allerdings
corona ihr könnt zu hause bleiben meine
videos gucken und abonniert
jetzt unter dem video
solche auch noch oft die folgen dann re
also auf einem kanal
gut lassen
[Musik]